2020 arrived it was hailed as a double
digits year something that was pretty
special
that only happens every hundred years or
so
well special it certainly was
[Music]
by the end of the month we had an
inkling that things were about to get
worse
far worse kovid 19 can be
characterized as a pandemic
the fashion industry soon was doing what
it does
best predicting what we would all soon
be wearing
masks soon they were hot
property arrests for selling contraband
masks became
headline news as the government
requisitioned them all
for health authorities
during the first wave nurses had to deal
with not only the coronavirus epidemic
but with the shortage of masks gloves
and overcoats
we ended up wearing trash bags at a time
when everyone was supposed to be
fighting the pandemic
we were left without the means of doing
so there was a lack of equipment
and the french government was
responsible for that there should have
been strategic stocks of surgical masks
and other gear
now things really started to go
downhill france announced its first
lockdown and the borders were closed
we work in the stadiums in the theaters
we ensure security in the events sector
and since march everything has been
stopped and it still hasn't resumed
all the hotels were closed there were
very very few hotels open
during the first wave the hotels that
stayed open did so to
accommodate people in difficulties
there was an enormous amount of worry
and we didn't have the sense of being
heard
a long confined spring left many with
pent-up energy as restrictions eased up
healthcare workers filled the streets
furious at being
underpaid and under appreciated
a summer drew to an end warnings of a
second
wave more deadly than the first filled
the air
paris took action introducing mask
measures as record new infections were
registered
then as autumn hit the closures began
again
anger was palpable
the government promised these measures
would be enough
there would be no return to a second
lockdown
instead a curfew that promise
fell like a pack of cards before the
month
was out
after consultation with scientists
dialogue with economic political and
social players
and after exchanges with all of our eu
partners and weighing the pros and cons
i've decided that as of friday we need
to go back to the lockdown that stopped
the virus
by now businesses were really feeling
the squeeze
for us 2020 was a horrible year and we
have the impression that
2021 is going to be even worse our
biggest problem in the catering industry
is that there is no recovery date and no
restart date
there are inconsistencies in how things
were decided it's been said that there
are
certain sectors that were able to resume
that's not a problem but it's the others
that are paying it's absurd things are
still very bad because we have
asked to restart our work but we can't
we have to continue paying our expenses
except there is no money coming back to
us there's nothing in fact
as france headed into the winter it
still
wasn't out of the woods
nursing staff learned from the first
wave we can now take better care of
patients
but the government has failed to learn
its lessons there is the problem of
hospital bed shortages
and lack of means to deal with the virus
and during the partial lockdown we saw
that 35
of infection clusters were in education
institutions
but the government did nothing about
that there were serious mistakes by the
government
and it makes us question our confidence
in the authorities
as the year drew to an end restaurants
bars theaters museums all remained
shells of their
former selves a fresh curfew was
announced and france finds itself facing
an uncertain future
as the bells ring in for twenty twenty
one
charlottinski rt paris
you